today is going to be the most amazing
day of your life your paper you say the
same thing every day Andre and every day
you're wrong
trying to hide little man you want my
wallet I want your gun you believe this
clown
nice to beef you what just happened this
is the movie that we're going to make
this was all staged yeah all of the
actors my answer is no that sound
doesn't deserve you do you hear me Kevin
Darnell Hart is a National Treasure
I think I see it
what is that oh no no let's make that
your mark whoop nope stop right there
some guy was trying to kill me
live action movie We're improving all
the action scenes
I'm literally trying to murder us Kevin
what you've been here not my blood
does that feel fake ow
no no no no wait look there's a
photographer look watch your picture
can't walk around with bloody clothes on
that's a man right there who's that my
dad he's been gone a long time he jumped
in the way of a knife meant for Richard
Pryor oh my God why would somebody want
to kill Richard Pryor
there's only one man who can help you
find who's behind this hello science has
no soliciting go away yeah no we didn't
we didn't see a sign there's no sign we
didn't take it
it's me it's Kevin Hart
well how do you like your tea
do I make you uncomfortable I'm just so
nervous for you sir because you got
really hot tea and it's just right above
your butt that is a trailer moment